what is up guys Jerry coming at you i'm
out run a couple errands and i figured i
would stop in here really quick and not
talk about a movie with you because you
know movies yeah i'm so recently ryan
and i watched a rather controversial
film something that has been a topic of
very much debate in the world recently
and of course i am talking about the
James Franco Seth Rogen masterpiece the
interview um yeah so um this movie
obviously has garnered a lot of
attention recently and you know the
first time I saw this trailer I was a
little bit surprised to say the least I
mean I saw the trailer for this movie
and I was like wow that's audacious I'm
kind of surprised this got made a little
bit I certainly hope it doesn't piss
anybody in the world off and it seems
like it may have so that's terrifying
anyway um the first trailer looked like
it'd kind of be cool and out there and I
actually thought they were playing
themselves again I thought they were
sort of taking on this sort of this is
the end style for this but now they play
characters and this movie is an
interesting one because for all the
controversy all the debate all of the
though we don't back down we need to
screen this everywhere this movie is
important um I mean it's kind of a lot
of commotion over a over a super okay
let's get into this so this movie stars
Seth Rogen and James Franco you know
Seth Rogen is the director producer of
this interview talk show sort of
celebrity tabloid thing and James Franco
is the host and it turns out the supreme
leader of North Korea is really big fan
and wants to do an interview on the show
ahhh it's crazy so
okay here's the thing this movie all the
hype surrounding and all the commotions
surrounding all the controversy is kind
of what what at least I sort of expected
which is a lot much do over an alright
movie the thing about this movie from me
ultimately like the big sort of
overarching thing is that it never truly
hits a stride I don't think I mean the
problem is you have these two main
characters you have Seth Rogen and James
Franco who generally you know on screen
I enjoy watching and the problem here is
that while I was initially excited to
see James Franco doing the the the more
funny the more silly role and Seth Rogen
taking the straight man again you know
it worked I thought really well at
pineapple express it doesn't really work
here partly because the movie wants to
have its cake and eat it too in the
sense that do you have James Franco who
is so over-the-top most of the time that
it doesn't always match the movie
sometimes he's much bigger than the
movie and any of the other characters
are so then you find yourself sitting
there going who would ever put up with
this guy and then you have Seth Rogen
who is sometimes really good in this
like sometimes he and James Franco play
off each other and it's great there are
certain scenes there's certain little
moments that are great and the interplay
is delightful but when James Franco
leaves when he's off screen all of a
sudden the movie wants Seth Rogen to be
the funny guy and it doesn't seem like
the movie ever drawers or at least pays
enough attention to the rules of its
universe and who its characters are so
you get these two guys who were just
kind of bumbling and silly and not
enough command over any one thing to
really make it more than a mess like I
guess like I'm all for absurdity I'm all
for suspension of disbelief and and
silly comedy and fun and all that but
you still have to draw the rules of your
universe well enough and pay attention
to them so that I'm not sitting here
every five to ten minutes asking myself
how
guys not been killed like a hundred
times by now how these guys not died or
been captured a hundred times over and I
found myself wondering that a lot during
this movie I didn't want to be the
supporting cast is really good Lizzy
Caplan's great I wish she was in this
more because she's one of the best parts
of this movie and you know that's a
character that is well drawn and then
you have Randall Park playing Kim Jong
hoon who does a great job he does a
great job in this movie playing Kim Jong
and also playing him like an actual
character because as silly as this movie
does make him and that I think is where
the biggest controversy comes from at
least as far as North Korea is concerned
if they're concerned it's just that this
movie ultimately makes him look silly
which isn't biting social commentary
there's nothing really challenging here
in terms of the ideas it's not gripping
biting satire by any stretch of the
imagination this movie is less
sophisticated than the controversy might
have you believe but just the same I
mean it is you know a legitimate form of
commentary if not a sophisticated one to
basically say this man is not a god you
know he pees and poos just like the rest
of us and it makes him look silly which
I can understand why somebody would be
mad because it does make him look silly
at a time stupid but it also plays him
like an actual character which I do
appreciate about this movie Randall Park
brings a lot to it and the whole movie
gets better in that half the second half
of their actually in North Korea is not
perfect still suffers from the same
problems as the first half but less so
it's got more of a direction it's got
more of an objective and and certain
plot points you know don't play out the
way you'd expect until I appreciate them
this is a movie that could have
definitely benefited from more editing
as is sort of the pit full of any of
these movies there are a lot of scenes
that go on for a bit too long and there
are some jokes that just go on for bit
too long end and in some cases the jokes
don't even change it's like that whole
scene where they're doing the whole like
we want you to take him out and they
don't understand what they mean it's not
even that they have a million different
ways of misinterpreting take him out
it's all like dinner jokes so it's just
a little bit like you could have cut the
scene down and it would have been fine
so this movie ultimately rounds out as
being super okay like there's a lot of
stuff that doesn't work and there's some
stuff that does work that's not overly
smart and it's not overly biting or
subversive political social commentary
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
but it's also not that competent of a
comedy either just just a straight up as
a straight up comedy this is one of
those movies where I wasn't having as
much fun watching it as it seemed like
they were having while making it so
ultimately you're left with a pile of
things that sort of works sort of
doesn't work if this was just a really
solid comedy that happened to have some
some you know political trappings it's
like oh I wish this would have been a
little more you know biting but hey good
job anyway but this movie you know sort
of never comes together as quite a
cohesive whole I left allowed four or
five times maybe I chuckled here and
there there are some fun cameos I quite
enjoyed the M&M scene to the point right
I kind of want that to be true I won't
spoil it there's certain really funny
recurring jokes that I like there are
certain things that sort of recur to the
point where you can't help but laugh at
them I'm kind of glad I saw it on
YouTube you know from the comfort of
Ryan's own home because that way you
know it's low risk that's the kind of
movie this is it's like you know rent it
with your buddies it'll be fun if it's
your thing you're gonna like it if it's
not your thing you're not going to like
it and if you're looking for something
truly dangerous and satirical probably
not the move
for you but yeah what did you think if
you saw did you like the interview did
you not like the interview and yeah what
do you want to see James Franco and Seth
Rogen take on next or their whole you
know team really take on next so yeah
that's it for now until next time I am
Jerry the interview is the film cheers